ونتابع مشاهدينا ايضا هذه الصور من مدينه
هاتاي التركيه هذه الصور المباشره حيث
يواصل عمال الانقاذ عمليات البحث عن ناجين
بين انقاضي المباني التي انهارت بسبب هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب
سوريا اذا مشاهدينا الحاصيه الاجماليه حتى
الان لعدد القتلى في تركيا وسوريا تجاوزت
الخمسه الاف قتيل بعدها هزات ارضيه عنيفه
ضربت مناطق قريبه من الحدود التركيه
السوريه بلغت قوتها 7 درجات فاصله ثمانيه
نذكر ايضا بما ذكرته اداره الكوارث
التركيه التي اكدت ارتفاع عدد قتل هذا
زلزال في تركيا الى
وارتفاع عدد الجرحى ايضا الى 20,000
واربعمائه وسته وعشرين جريحا هذه الصور
المباشر المشاهدين اذا لعمليه الانقاذ من
مدينه هاتاي التركيه